[موسيقى]
اذاء الغيم تنهمر
الحروف لها نغم يحس به
الشغوف يرى فيها غصونا
باسقات على اطرافها تدن
القطوف فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني
مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال
الدهر قد جاز
[موسيقى]
الوقوف سال علي بن الحسين امراه ما الحب
فقالت اخفى من ان يظهر وابين من ان يخفى
ثم انشدت ان المحبين في شغل لسيدهم كفتيه
الكهف لا يدرون كم لبثوا السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم بيت
العنكبوت يضرب به المثل في الضعف والوهن
يقول الله تعالى في سوره العنكبوت وان
اوهن البيوت لبيت العنكبوت لو كانوا
يعلمون وقد اشار الفرزدق الى هذا المعنى
الذي جاء في كتاب الله تعالى يقول الفرزدق
لجرير في معرض الهجاء ضربت عليك العنكبوت
بنسجها وقضى عليك به الكتاب المنزل وقال
الاحنف العكبري العنكبوت بنت بيتا على وهن
تاوي اليه ومالي مثلها وطن والخنفساء لها
من جنسها سكن وليس لي مثلها الا ولا سكن
وقال اخر انما الدنيا عناء ليس للدنيا
ثبوت انما الدنيا كبيت نسجته
العنكبوت ويقول الحمدو معرضا بطي ساني
احمد ابن
حرب يا ابن حرب كسوتني طيلسانا مل من صحبه
الزمان وصدا فحسبنا نسج العناكب لو قيس
الى نسج طي سانك سدا ان تنفست فيه ينشق
شقا او تنحنحت فيه ينقد قدا طال ترداده
الى الرفو حتى لو بعثناه وحده
لتهد الطيلسان هو ضرب من الاوشحه يلبس على
الكتف ومعنى الرفو اصلاح الثوب بالخياطه
وضم بعضه على بعض وفي البيت الاخير يقول
الشاعر الحموي ان هذا الطيلسان الذي
اهديتني يا احمد ابن حرب صار يهتدي الى
طريق الخياط وحده لكثره ما اخذ الى هناك
للاصلاح وقصه هذا الطيلسان طريفه جدا ذلك
ان احمد ابن حرب اهداه للشاعر الحمدو ثم
صار يذكره له في كل حين وصار يمن عليه
بهذه الهديه مع ان الطيلسان اي هذا الوشاح
كان مهترئ جدا واذكر ان صديقا لي اقرضني
مبلغا من المال وفعل فيه مثل وفعل به مثل
ما فعل ابن حرب مع الحمدو بالعوده الى
العنكبوت يقول الفراء العنكبوت انثى وقد
يذكرها بعض العرب وانشد قوله على ه طالهم
منهم بيوت كان العنكبوت هو ابتنا والتانيث
في العنكبوت اكثر والجمع العنكبوت
والعناكب والعناكب
وتصغيرها عنيك
وعنيك وقد حكى سيبويه عن كباء وقال ابن
الاعرابي العنكب الذكر منها
[موسيقى]
حكي ان عبد الله بن جعفر رضي الله عنهم
كان على فرسه فتعرض له رجل في الطريق
فتمسك بعنان فرسه وقال سالتك بالله ايها
الامير ان تضرب عنقي فبهت عبد الله وقال
احمق انت قال لا قال له فما الخبر قال لي
خصم لدود قد لزمني وضيق علي وليس لي به
طاقه قال له الامير ومن خصمك قال الفقر
فالتفت عبد الله الى فتاه وقال ادفع له 1ف
دينار ثم قال يا اخ العرب خذها واذا عاد
اليك خصمك
متغشكر ان معي من جودك ما ادحض به حجه
خصمي بقيه عمري ثم اخذ المال وان
صرف قالوا ان السحائب لا تجدي بوارقها
نفعا اذا هي لم تمطر على الاثر وقالوا
لولا المشقه ساد الناس كلهم الجود يفقر
والاقدام قد
[موسيقى]
تال
يحكى ان اعرابيا نزل عند حاتم الطائي فبات
عنده جائعا دون ان يقدم له حاتم شيئا فلما
كان السحر راكب الرجل وانصرف فسبقه حاتم
متنكرا وقال اين كان مبيتكررش
بخير حال فقال له انا حاتم والله لا تبرح
حتى ترى ما وصفت فرده اليه واكرمه ثم ساله
ما حملك على الكذب فقال الاعرابي ان الناس
كلهم يثنون عليك بالجود والكرم فلو قلت
شرا لكذب وي فرجعت مضطرا الى قولهم ابقاء
على نفسي لا ابقاء
علي الم تعلمي اني اذا الضيف نابني وعز
القرا اقر السديف المسره يقولون لي اهلكت
ماالك فاقتصد وما كنت لولا ما يقولون
سيدا محمد كريشان يروي واليكم التفاصيل
كتاب صادر عن جسور للترجمه والنشر الزميل
الاستاذ محمد
كريشان في البدايه يقول هذا الكتاب ليس
سيره ذاتيه ولا توثيقا تاريخيا انه ببساطه
مجرد محطات متناثره ظلت عالقه في ذاكره
صحفي امتزج فيها السرد بالراي وتداخل
المهني بالشخصي لعل القارئ يجد بعض
الفائده هنا او هناك اقول يجد الفائده نعم
ويجد المتعه ويجد التسليه ويرضي فضوله اذا
كان مثلي
فضوليا الجميل عندما تقرا لمحمد كريشان
انه لا يحدثك بروايه قيل عن قال بل يقول
كنت مع القذافي وقال لي كنت مع علي عبد
الله صالح كنت
مع الرئيس الفلاني او الامير الفلاني
او الملك الفلاني ويسوق لك ال الروايات
بطريقه قصصيه جميله وهو صاحب قلم جميل وله
مقال اسبوعي في جريده القدس العربي
بالمناسبه يحدثك مثلا عن اول مهمه خارجيه
اوكلت اليه حينما اوفد ته جريده الراي ل
الذهاب الى ليبيا لكتابه تقارير تتعلق
بليبيا القذافي يقول ا انهم اوكل
ا سائقا معه سياره من اجل ان يكون مرافقا
لي يقول طبعا يعني ما كنت اعلم الا ان هذا
الرجل سائق يعني ومعه سياره ولكن عندما
طلب مني الانتظار في السياره ونزل لقضاء
بعض الحاجات يقول تناولت الجريده من
المقعد الخلفي وعندما فتحتها وجدت ان
الرجل ليس الا
اي عنصرا امنيا وقد شرع في كتاب التقرير
عني وكتب في
ال الورقه هذه انه محمد كريشان صحفي في
جريده الرايه التونسيه ولكن ما عنده
كاميرا عنده مسجل وهذه الاغراض الرئيسيه
للصحفي يقول بسرعه يعني طويت الجريده
واعدت الجريده الى مكانها ويقول وبعد ذلك
ما طال بي الوقت قبل ان اشتري المسجل
والكاميرا
هذا هذا الموقف طبعا كان الرجل يعني
يمكن يعني في مرحله قصيره بعد التخرج من
الجامعه يتحدث عن محمد حسنين هيكل
مثلا و وضح لك اعجابه الشديد بهذا الرجل
ومقابلاته الكثيره معه وكيف انهما يشتركان
في حب اللون الكحلي البدل الكحلي وكيف ان
احدهما قلد الاخر يقول لابد انني انا الذي
قلدت الاستاذ يقول في مقابلتي معه في لندن
على الجزيره نهايه عام 2010 جاء ذكر
السيجار حين اشار هيكل الى انه التقى ذات
مره بالرئيس الامريكي جون
كندي فقدم له الرئيس سيجارا سرعان ما لاحظ
هيكل انه ليس من النوع الرفيع
بل وصفه بانه
فالصو يقول فعرض عليه سيجارا من عنده فلما
ساله كندي يعني سال هيكل قال له هذا كوبي
فانتفض كندي قال يعني صحيح انه بديع لكن
لا استطيع ان ادخنه يعني تخيل لو اشتمت في
البيت الابيض رائحه سيجار كوبي ستصبح قضيه
وقد يعزلني
الكونجرس في نهايه الكتاب ملحق للصور تجد
فيه مثلا صوره نادره لمحمد كريشان وهو
يدخن السيجار وتحتها مكتوب انني كنت ادخن
مع محمد حسنين هيكل مجامله موضوع ايضا
طريف انه كان الرئيس
الموريتاني الذي انقلب
على محمد ولد الشيخ عبد الله فهو كان
التقى الرئيس القديم في مدريد وبعدها
الاسبوع التقى الرئيس الذي انقلب عليه
في موريتانيا فساله يعني انه انت ليش
انقلبت قال لانه هذا يجري تعيينات عسكريه
وهذا يغير في في الهيكليه قال طيب ما هو
القائد الاعلى للجيش والقوات المسلحه يعني
يحق له ان يعدل هذه قال نعم يحق له لكن مو
في الليل فهو لانه في
الليل فيقول من حقه ولكن ليس بالليل ف
الحس الفكاهي عند محمد
كريشان عالي حقيقه انا اذكر انه في بدايه
الثوره
الليبيه كان في لقاء على الهواء مع وكيل
وزاره الخارجيه الليبيه وكان الرجل منكرا
لاي يعني حراك في البلاد فكان محمد كريشان
يسال عن الاوضاع والرجل يقول انتم صهاينه
في الجزيره انتم اسال حمد بن جاسم عن
لقائه مع الاسرائيليين قال له يا اخي احنا
فعلا احنا صهاينا واحنا خونا وانت كشفتنا
الان لكن ممكن تجاوبني على سؤالي فالرجل
ليس من النوع اللي ممكن انه يتورط على
الهواء دائما الحجه
حاضره الحس الفكاهي حاضر والكتاب جميل جدا
ويستحق القراءه محمد كريشان يرويه واليكم
[موسيقى]
التفاصيل
في تويتر سالتكم ما اجمل بيت قاله شاعر حي
وشعرائنا كلهم احياء ولكنني قصدت الشعراء
المعاصرين الموجودين الان في هذه الفتره
فيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من
المشاركات هذه مشاركه من عبد الله العتيبي
يقول عزائي ان منزلكم قريب وان هوى الاحبه
في باقي واجمل منه ان كنت صبحا في زمان
حالك فعلى جبيني حاجب
منصور لقد نصرت الحاجب مرتين يا ابا عمر
والعين
ايضا احمد خليفه استحضر بيتا للشاعر
الليبي الكبير والاديب الاستاذ محمد
المزوغي قالوا الصباح فقلت وجهك ما لنا
الاه في ظلم الحياه صباح لا خير الا كان
حبك بابه اما الصلاه عليك فالمفتاح عليه
الصلاه
والسلام عبد السلام بكار اورد بيتا للشاعر
محمد المقرن يقول انا الغريب بارض لا اراك
بها الروح عندك اما سافر الجسد في ضجه
الناس بات الشوق يعزلني كانني في بلاد ما
بها احد الله على هذه الاختيارات الجميله
محمد
الجلبي اورد بيتا للشاعر كريم العراقي في
قصيده هل المواساه حررت يوما وطنا لا تشكو
للناس جرحا انت صاحبه لا يؤلم الجرح الا
من به
الم ومشاركه من ايناس تقول ان تفضيل بيت
واحد على الشعر كله لشديد ولكن احسن انس
الدغيم حين قال وليس يلام السيف وهو مهند
اذا خانت السيف المهند ساعدوا
وهذا بيت جميل ايضا من
ميسره فارقت اذ فارقت ضيم جوار فارقت اذ
فارقت ضيم جوارنا ولد المهيمن لا يضام
جواره الشاعر ايمن العتوم في رثاء صاحبه
رحمه
الله مشاركه من عبد
المعين الغصن ينبت غصنا حين نقطعه والليل
ينجب صبح حين يكتمل انس
الحجري وهذه مشاركه من اشواق وقد اوردت
بيتا للشاعر المصري احمد بخيت قدر القصيده
ان تؤرخ وحدها وجع الضحيه لا يد
الجلاد وبهذا البيت الجميل اصل معكم الى
ختام هذه
المشاركات من الشعراء الاحياء اورد لكم
بيتا تذوقته زمنا طويلا وما زلت اشعر انه
يرن في راسي رنينا جميلا كلما ذكرته
للشاعر العراقي زكي الياسري يقول فيه
خلاصه العمر ايام اراك بها وما عداها من
الايام تبذير ولا ينبغي باي حال من
الاحوال ان اذكر الشعراء الاحياء دون ان
اعرج بالكبير الجميل الرائع جاسم الصحيح
الذي
يقول ما عاد يملا راسي خمر داليه صبي
جمالك حتى يمتلي راسي كل النساء احاديث
بلا سند وانت انت حديث لابن
عباس شكرا لكم على المشاركات الجميله
واذكركم دائما بان تضعوا وسم تاملات
[موسيقى]
الجزيره
عن علم من اعلام العراق احدثكم ابراهيم
السام
الرائي هل سيظل العراق مظلوما وهل سيبقى
العالم العربي اصم اعمى عن 60 كتابا نشرها
ابراهيم
السامرائي يروي احمد علاو مؤلف سيرته كيف
كان السامرائي وهو شيخ جاوز السبعين ينتقل
من دائره حكوميه الى اخرى في الاردن لينال
بطاقه الاقامه وهو العضو في مجمع اللغه
العربيه الاردني والمحاضر في الجامعه
الاردنيه وكيف اضطر اخيرا الى ان ياخذ
ورقه من مكتب هندسي تقول انه يعمل في ذلك
المكتب في اربعينيات القرن الماضي نرى
ابراهيم السام الرائي الطالب في معهد
اعداد المعلمين يجلس الى زميله صبحي
البصام في مقهى البرازيليه في شارع الرشيد
ببغداد يتناقشان في اللغه ويختلفان في
تقييم غزاره علم الاساتذه طاه الراوي
ومصطفى جواد ومهدي المخزومي ومضت الاعوام
ونال السام الرائي الدكتوراه من السوربون
وظل يناقش زميله القديم عبر الصحف في
موضوعات اللغه قامت بينهما معركه ادبيه
ساخنه يقول عنها صبحي البصام اختلفنا في
الراي ولكن دون ان تركب حده او تزري بنا
جفوه كانت معركه هادئه كانت غبارا سقط على
الذهب فمسحه فعاد الى الذهب
[موسيقى]
بريقه يروي وديع فلسطين المؤرخ المصري كيف
وصل ابراهيم السامرائي مره متاخرا الى
اجتماع مجمع اللغه العربيه في القاهره
فسئل عن ذلك فاجاب بغضب بعد ثلاث ساعات من
الانتظار الممل والمذل في المطار بسبب
عراقيه اذن لي بالدخول حقا ان وصف العرب
بانهم اشقاء مغاير للحقيقه بل هم اشقياء
ويضيف وديع فلسطين خطبته بلقب دكتور وهو
في صناعه التاليف والترجمه حجه امره
فنهاني وقال لي انه اخذ يسقط اللقب من
اغلفه كتبه بعد ما هزل اللقب على ايدي
الدكاتره
المحدثين السامراء ولد في العماره بالعراق
وتيتم من ابويه طفلا فرته خالته وفي زمن
قبل الاستقلال استطاع بنبوغه ان ينال منحه
الى السوربون بباريس وعاد بشهاده
الدكتوراه واما في العراق المستقل فهو لم
ينل حتى العضويه في مجمع اللغه العربيه
العراقي وعلق قائلا هذه وظيفه تتم
بالتعيين ولم
اعين درس السهم الرائي اللغتين العبريه
والسريانيه في العراق وله باع في الفرنسيه
ونشر بها ابحاثا يتعقب ابراهيم السامرائي
في العديد من كتبه الكلمات والاساليب
الدارجه ويعيدها الى اصولها فهو صاحب لغات
شرقيه وغربيه
كثيره توفي ابراهيم السامرائي مغتربا في
الاردن عام 2001 وقد قارب الثمين وشيعه
قله ممن عرفوا
فضله الاحاطه بجهود ابراهيم السامرائي لا
تكفيها هذه الفقره في برنامجنا ولا يكفيها
حتى كتاب براس
ولكن دعونا نذكر بعض ما التقطه الرجل من
التعبيرات الاجنبيه التي دخلت الى اللغه
العربيه بالفاظ
مستورده السهر على المصلحه العامه لفظ
مستورد ذر الرماد في العيون كذلك توتر
العلاقات اللعب بالنار اجاب بالحرف الواحد
يبكي بكاء مرا دموع التماسيح القضيه
مطروحه على بساط البح بحث كل هذه تعابير
مستورده على قدم المساواه حجر عثره
الاصطياد في الماء العكر نزولا عند رغبته
بكل معنى الكلمه وضع النقاط على الحروف
مؤتمر المائده المستديره بالعين المجرده
ان لم تخني الذاكره التراب الوطني جرح
شعوره كسر الرقم القياسي يعلق اهميه كبيره
الجنس اللطيف عاصفه من التصفيق عندما اقول
ان كل هذه تعابير مستورده فهذا معناه انك
اذا رايت رجلا يستخدمها فاعلم انه ليس
اصيلا في اللغه العربيه بل هو يفكر بلغه
اجنبيه ثم ينقل لك الكلام مترجما اما
العرب في قديم الزمان فما كانوا يقولون
مثل هذه التعبيرات التي التقطناها من كتاب
دراسات في اللغه وفيه يورد ابراهيم
السامرائي دائما الاصل الفرنسي او
الانجليزي او كليهما
ختاما اقول ان ابحاث السام الرائي النحويه
وحدها تضعه في مصاف كبار النحاه العرب في
عصرنا كلما امعن المرء في تقليب كتب
ابراهيم السام الرائي وراى ما عان في
حياته شعر اننا لا نستحق هذا اللغوي
الكبير ويظل العراق ظالما
ومظلوم
[موسيقى]
يا من تغش وملء العين
صورتها قولي لعطرك اني لست
قديسا كانك البدر رغم الغيم يحرسه يبدو
لعيني تدريسا
فتيس اسب ابليس لكني ابرئ الذنب عيناك ليس
الذنب ابليس السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم